although kite news look very simple  these mollusks have a very sophisticated  shell the shells outer layer is full of  black bumps that on close inspection  turn out to be very tiny eyes  complete with light-sensitive cells and  a lens surprisingly the eyes lens is  made of the same calcium carbonate  material as the rest of the shell while  most of the opaque shell consists of  tiny irregularly oriented grains the  grains and the lens are much larger and  aligned to let light pass through with  little scattering researchers have shown  that these eyes can actually see each  one forms a complete image on its retina  a fish in these experiments at best  the Titans can probably detect predators  up to two metres away giving them an  opportunity to clamp down tight and  avoid being eaten  Titans can't move very fast so they  depend on their hard armor to keep them  safe the eyes are chinks in that armor  but as they provide advanced warning of  any attacks still more than make up for  it